usually is with us in Tennessee hi Julie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
okay so I have a couple questions I took
your advice and I went to East Tennessee
State University instead of Vanderbilt
so I third of the cost for my nurse
practitioner degree and I am currently
in twenty-three thousand dollars in debt
from this current semester for my nurse
practitioner and my undergrad so I have
forty thousand dollars saved up I don't
know if I should just write that check
now for that twenty three thousand
dollars and only have seventeen thousand
dollars left in my savings account or
what you would suggest I think it's kind
of scary to write that check when I do I
have forty thousand okay are you out of
school I'm currently getting my nurse
practitioner so I have a year left and I
work full time as a nurse here all right
how are you paying for that my nurse
practitioner I've been just trying to I
took out a loan for this semester and
that is included in the $23,000 okay you
had $40,000 in the bank and you took out
a loan
yes I get really scared to pay a little
bit I just say feet up and I just you
should've gone to school if you weren't
willing to pay for it okay yeah that's
true
well I think I write just a big check at
the end but okay I'm asking okay if how
are you going to pay to finish school
either take out loans or work which I
have been doing and pay as I go okay so
how much do you make working well
Nashville nursing prices are a little
slim so it's like 40,000 and then I have
the option I could also move my leases
off and move to a different state where
I make twice as much - so I'm sorry the
UM where are you studying nurse
practitioner East Tennessee State so
it's a distance learning thing yeah it's
online so that's why
to work as well as go online school and
you can finish your nurse practitioner
online huh okay and what will it cost to
finish the total for each times you say
it is like 35,000 does that tell you
that what it takes you to finish yeah
mm-hmm like total with all the whole
degree is about 35,000 east half of it
no I'm I have I'm in my first semester
and I have four more semesters to go
okay so you need $30,000 to finish yeah
I need about thirty thousand that I take
out in loans or pay as I go Jeana you
called Dave Ramsey don't say take out
loans anymore I'm going to go in the
hives I don't have chills okay we're not
gonna we're not gonna take any more
loans you're either not gonna finish or
you're not gonna take out loans I don't
care which we're not going to take out
loans now we're gonna pay cash for it
now how are we going to pay for it if we
use this forty thousand to finish then
you're gonna clean up the 23 later after
you finish no I I think we've got this
some of this forty thousand dollars
earmarked for you to finish school and
you'll use some of your income to do
that but you're living pretty tight if
you're able to finish the over what
period of time is left how much time how
much longer will it take you to finish I
have a year left one year you need
basically $25,000 right yep and you're
gonna pull that out you're gonna pull
that out of 40 no you're not that's not
gonna work
so I don't know right now $40,000 a
forty thousand our income you don't have
enough income to eat and pay for this
without using this savings even if I
work as I go and make around three
thousand a month $40,000 in one year and
you need $25,000 during the same year
you if you make 40 and you spend 25 on
your degree out of your
come that only leaves 15 - taxes you
don't have enough to exist yeah and I
pay 750 for rent I know it's very tight
which is $10,000 a year okay yeah okay
so yeah you know when we start adding up
your budget you probably need twenty
five thirty thousand dollars a year to
live and so you may have five or ten
thousand dollars out of your income to
throw at this but you need twenty five
you're gonna use some of your savings to
finish school kiddo uh-huh no more loans
yeah
stop it do I so I don't write attract
that not at all do not write a check for
the existing loans let them sit there
until you graduate you should you have
40 thousand dollars in savings did I
understand you're right yeah okay I
would use some of that money to finish
school - for the rest of school make no
more loans then when you graduate you
should have fifteen thousand dollars
left in your account a twenty three
thousand dollar loan and a better job
making as a nurse practitioner more than
forty yeah exactly and so we can use
that fifteen thousand towards the twenty
three thousand and we can clean up the
debt and begin to save again okay okay
that sounds good after graduating no
more borrowing raise your right hand say
no more borrowing no more borrowing I
won't
I won't Thank You Julie appreciate you
calling